demons that did Evil things which some
evil some demons did was a problem to
the ancient Mesopotamians and they were
feared so demons could be very ambiguous
creatures that could take on different
forms or no form at all but there are
certain famous demon personalities that
had certain characteristics and
personalities and were associated with
certain things one of the most famous of
these demons was lashu a frightening
female demon that was primar seen as a
great danger to children and newborn
babies indeed the thing she was most
feared for was that she would stalk
mothers and eat their babies either
before or after birth in other words
she's definitely a demon that represents
the dangers of childbirth and the
possibilities of miscarriage